Chooses amongst self replicating
entities.
Those self replicating entities have
some kind of power over that probability
of being copied,
of being replicated to being passed on.
In practice,
that almost always means choosing
between alternative DNA genes.
So it's about the natural selection,
the disproportionate,
it's about the unequal survival of genes
through generations that is not for
selection.
We see it in the form of changes in
phenotypes.
That's to say changes in bodies because
it's through the changes in the bodies
that the genes induce,
that they ensure their survival or fail
to survive.
The ones that are good at surviving are
the ones that are good at building
bodies that are good at surviving and
reproducing.
Where gene machines in the sense that
her body is constructed by genes that
have been successful in surviving in the
past.
They're good at surviving because
they're good at constructing machines in
which they survive.
So our body is a machine for the
propagation of the genes that built it.